I'm really excited to be with you guys
today
um the title of my talk the end of
History it's kind of a really nerdy word
play so the first part has to do with
like kind of moving past the cap theorem
which is something that kind of happened
a while ago very quietly and maybe
behind closed doors and Big Data Centers
and tech companies and it's a revolution
that's going to spread just as the
modern data stack is spread so I'm going
to be talking about that in my talk and
then the kind of double entender pieces
that
um we don't have to just query ancient
history as we do in a batch world we can
now it's going to get much easier to
query real-time data plus old history
hence the end of History
um I'm going to tell you a little story
about my past week
um so on the 24th I was in Switzerland
and verbier giving a talk about data
modeling in real time at the Leading
Edge it conference it's called skiers
and data it's a fantastic conference but
I highly recommend against doing two
conferences Europe and the US four days
apart so that was the 24th this is the
28th I actually don't know what day it
is I got in I got to sleep last night at
3am but we're gonna have a lot of fun
today and I'm really excited to be here
with you guys
um another aspect of this trip besides
the sleep deprivation and the jet lag is
some various experiences with Airlines
and either I have really bad air travel
Karma or I was blessed with an
opportunity to talk about real-time data
in a very practical context so I'll get
back back to that in a second but anyway
if I say anything insightful that's
definitely my own Brilliance if I say
anything stupid that's definitely sleep
deprivation and jet lag so
um I'll ask for your forbearance in that
respect okay so when I was flying to uh
to Geneva to go to verbier the Airlines
lost my bag major International Airline
lost my bag and then a day before I flew
out my bag arrived at my hotel kind of
got all cleaned up got fresh clothes on
and then I flew back to JFK
and they the another International
Airline that's a partner of the first
airline lost my bag again and so this is
an opportunity to see
um what impact real-time data can have
in businesses today uh specifically at
about 1 30 a.m as I was at JFK talking
to the baggage agent for this Airline
about where my bag was she said she was
looking this up in a system and she said
well I see one event here and there
should be two events so the event that
shows up is that my bag arrived in
Amsterdam supposed to go back to JFK and
so it got scanned and authorized to go
back to the US and then there's supposed
to be a second event that says hey this
bag has been loaded into a container and
then it's going to go on the 777 and
it's going to fly back to the US but the
second event was not there so it looked
like the bag just somehow didn't make
the plane maybe because it was a close
connection now this had me dreaming
about what we could do with real-time
technology in a real-time World using
streaming analytics we could do things
like when the plane takes off there's an
event and then you check for events for
various bags just say here's an event
that authorizes this bag to get on the
plane and we're missing a second event
that is supposed to load the bag on the
plane and then as I log on to the Wi-Fi
on the plane I get a message that says
hey we apologize it looks like your bag
didn't make it onto this plane and then
I can start a chat to arrange what
happens with my bag at that point and in
particular I could arrange that I'm
going to JFK but I'm going on to Austin
and so let's make sure that the bag gets
forwarded to Austin and with this kind
of Technology with this kind of data
technology everyone is a lot happier the
airline's happier because the situation
gets resolved much more quickly the
customer's happier because they're not
wondering where their bag is and
standing at the badger claim for an hour
waiting for it to show up then trying to
find the baggage office waiting in line
talking to someone who then has to
figure out what's going on
um
it's fashionable it has been fashionable
for some time to talk about being data
driven in business but the reality is
that virtually every business now is
data driven what does it mean to be data
driven well we saw with the situation at
Southwest Airlines that every system
every flight every every employee every
action of many of these businesses is
tied to data there's a database that
determines where Airline Personnel go
there are databases that determine when
flights take off and when bags get
delivered and when they get loaded on
planes and if there's a failure anywhere
in that chain it will bring down the
entire business and cause it to grind to
a halt and so I think it's time to talk
more about not about data being data
driven but about data performance again
every business is data driven data
performance is about doing better things
with data like making your data more
real time more accessible better serving
your customer needs getting more
insights and of course from a business
perspective obviously making more money
that's what businesses try to do but
when they make more money ideally their
employees have more opportunities their
shareholders have more opportunities
there are many many good things in
principle that can come from being more
data performance and in particular I'm
going to talk about real-time technology
and how the
we've seen a lot of movement in real
time in the last decade but it's kind of
stalled at the same time and yet from my
perspective there's a quiet Revolution
happening that hasn't spread into the
culture of tech quite yet but will in
the next few years and will be a massive
augmentation to the modern data stack
and the impact it's had on businesses
okay
um who am I
I'm Matt Housley so I have a PhD in
mathematics actually and I taught for
about a decade between grad school
postdoc in just my career before moving
into the data space I worked in the data
space for a number of years and then
switched over to running a consulting
company which I co-founded with Joe
Reese called ternary data and so frankly
we used to do a lot of services work we
kind of shifted more into the advising
space technology advising training
advising investors advising small and
large companies about where to go with
technology to be successful
and I'm also co-author sorry I have two
there we go I'm also so a co-author of
this book with Joe Reese fundamentals of
data engineering and so in this book we
try to focus both on the technology and
the process act aspect of data how does
data engineering really impact a
business and how should you think about
data engineering processes and so this
talk today Builds on those basic ideas
um I would love to talk to you about it
about things you agree with things you
object to and so track me down later at
this conference if you have ideas about
the book or talk to me some other time
if we don't get to connect here
all right
when I talk about the end of History one
of the things I'm talking about is the
cap theorem can someone tell me what the
CA and p stand for in the cap theorem
yes consistency availability partition
tolerance okay what does this mean in
practice let's talk about the Practical
aspects of the cap theorem
um
fundamentally consistency well okay let
me back up just a second here
um
really this is the the original theorem
is more about uh distributed data store
and I actually agree with Jordan tagani
the Big Data As We Knew It is dead but
we still need distributed data stores
like they're still really fundamental
for businesses so these are problems we
have to talk about and so with the
distributed data store you have to worry
about problems of consistency and so the
idea of consistency is that when I make
a read on that distributed data store
whatever I see the latest updates
whatever has been written I will see in
a response to my query or I'll get an
error the database might just tell me
that it can't respond at that time to a
particular query but it'll be one of the
two I'm not going to get inconsistent
data if my database is fully consistent
availability means that I'll always get
a response
um it might be an incorrect response if
my database doesn't satisfy the first
bullet point it might be but I will
never get an error always always get
some kind of response to my query
partition intolerance has to do with a
distributed system anytime you have a
distributed system you're going to get
partitions meaning nodes can't
communicate traffic gets lost this
happens even inside your own data center
you can't guarantee that your network is
going to work correctly 100 of the time
you're going to have problems in any
distributed system where there's a lack
of communication and so partition
tolerance basically on some level means
your beta database behaves correctly
when
there's a lack of communication it's not
just going to fall over
um there are more technical details here
obviously but the big idea of the cap
theorem is that you can't have all three
of these you can't get all of these in
one
um obviously we could go on and debate
about Google Cloud spanner for example
and if it's a counter example of the cap
theorem and people say well not really
for various reasons but we're not going
to get too far into that because mostly
I care about an analytics application of
this idea and which is I'm a math person
PhD is math so I like corollaries this
is essentially a corollary to the cap
theorem so in designing a database or
distributed data store we could choose
one of the following so I can either
have an acid database with high rate
asynchronous updates and so think of
postgres in a typical mode backing an
application say a bank account
application which is a really common
example where I need absolute
consistency I need transactions I need I
need to make sure that two people don't
withdraw money from an account at the
same time and overdraw it these are the
kinds of characteristics that get an
acid database will give me and typically
you can have like thousands of
transactions per second so you can very
very quick updates in general that will
conflict with second application which
is fast analytics scans so in other
words the second bullet point is a
database that's designed to scan say
could be 100 gigabytes or terabyte of
data all at once very quickly and the
return statistical or analytical results
on that data and so the second type of
database is typically used in analytics
or machine learning applications and so
in general you can't satisfy both of
these things at the same time if you
I'll give you a very concrete example
there was a company I worked for at one
point and in the past in the old days
they had an asset database that backed
their website and so someone during a
presentation wanted to present some
analytics from this database and so they
ran a SQL query and the database
basically Grant or the website ground to
a halt because they were locking all
these rows running a huge query on this
database and so nothing else could
happen at the same time and so in terms
of the cap theorem the second type of
database essentially relaxes relaxes
consistency in other words you tend to
use especially in the modern columnar
version of an analytics database you
tend to use a snapshot model where you
kind of see the latest snapshot but
you're not going to try to keep track of
thousands of transactions per second
anymore and commonly we deal with this
by using a process called ETL so we keep
these two databases separate and then we
periodically in batch so going back to
the batch versus real-time idea in batch
we move data into the analytics database
once in a while
I keep okay
how do we beat the cap theorem so
you can't beat the house in Vegas and
you can't beat the cap theorem but there
are ways to kind of go around the cap
theorem
um fundamentally when we run into a
really hard problem often the solution
to that problem is to rethink the
assumptions to drop an assumption
somehow so for example Albert Einstein
special relativity people think that his
contribution was was to come up with the
Lorenz Transformations all these ideas
about how time and space transform if
you're in different frames but actually
his big contribution was to drop the
idea of an ether of a privileged frame
to say wait we don't really need this
let's get rid of it and see what happens
that's fundamentally what he did and so
with the cap theorem we can get around
the capturing by dropping a big
assumption
and actually this is from a post uh it's
actually a blog post that introduces a
fundamental architectural idea by Nathan
Mars and if you're interested in this
kind of thing I highly recommend that
you read it
um but he says this post is going to
challenge your basic assumptions on how
Data Systems should be built and so he
introduces something called the Lambda
architecture which we're going to talk
about today at this point that version
of the Lambda architecture is kind of
outmoded it's complicated it's hard to
query it's hard to manage but we're
going to talk about how that's evolved
and is something new that's more
accessible and
the Assumption he drops
we've already talked about having
multiple databases we have our
transactional database and we have our
analytics database and there's a
transfer between them in batch but his
assumption is instead let's have
multiple databases that operate semi in
real time
and so the basic architecture looks like
this for a Lambda architecture you have
your data source and messaging queue and
then instead of in batch just moving
data into a bulk system you actually
still do that but then you introduce
another database that's more real time
that's more of a streaming system now
the problem is the streaming system will
have some limitations requiring massive
amounts of data at once it's going to
struggle with that use case in some
cases and so instead you have two pieces
you can run large batch queries in your
batch portion and you can run small what
I'll call near real-time queries in your
streaming portion and then you can
combine the results and so for example
suppose my batch portion gets updated
once a day with a ton of data pulled out
of this messaging queue and then the
real-time portion maybe I'll query for
the last six hours since the last update
happened to the large system and then I
can get a picture of analytics across
say the last six weeks all at once I can
run two queries combine the results and
get a nice result that's near real time
the problem with this approach is that
it's complicated so
back when this came out if you handed it
to your data science team they know how
to deal with querying two systems
plus I'm going to talk about an
abstraction idea here there are many
ways to frame abstractions in technology
this is just kind of one heuristic for
doing this
over time we've moved up and up in the
abstraction layers but also our
architectures have gotten much much more
complicated so you start down at the
hardware level that's like your CPUs
back in the 1980s a long time ago when I
was a kid I used to do Assembly Language
programming on a Commodore 64. that's
the kind of thing we used to do back
then but a lot of the reason that
programming and software have advanced
is that we moved up this chain of
complexity and we've automated a lot of
the lower levels of abstraction
the problem with the Lambda architecture
as it was realized
is that people were still trying to
manage a lot of these pieces all the way
maybe not to the hardware level anymore
but there was a tendency at the time to
still operate at the operating system
level so install software in a bunch of
nodes and then at the next level
software Frameworks okay I'm going to
install Hadoop and I'm going to install
Kafka on these nodes and then I have the
cluster level cluster level is things
like in Hadoop I have to worry about
Hadoop nodes and zookeeper nodes it
turns out there are multiple clusters I
have to maintain within a Hadoop cluster
similar case with Kafka I have to
maintain all that stuff then the system
level the system is Kafka itself so all
the pieces that make up Kafka and then
all the pieces that make up Hadoop and
then on the last level with architecture
we can debate there's a lot of debate
about what exactly architecture is in
this case I'm using it to mean multiple
systems so in other words I'm using it
to mean this big picture here where I'm
maintaining multiple systems I have to
keep them all going I have to make the
different pieces interact correctly
behave and ideally not fall over at some
point maybe in the middle of the night
for a very business critical process
which the more the better this
technology becomes the more Mission
critical it becomes the more important
it is that it doesn't fall over
okay so that was a key problem with the
Lambda architecture there was the query
complexity and there's the maintenance
complexity now I'm going to show you
well actually I want to talk a bit more
about this
um I think in general in Tech right now
we have a complexity problem and the
complexity problem is that we are in
tech companies and Enterprises
maintaining very complex infrastructure
and this comes at a high human cost so
for example recently for a client I was
working on setting up data Hub which is
a data catalog system and so I set out a
template and I deployed managed Services
I got everything set up to do this for
the client I did in my own environment
and then I tried to deploy in their
environment too and it turned out that
between the time I started and the time
I tried to deploy there was an update to
Amazon eks and they had deprecated the
version of kubernetes we were using and
so I couldn't deploy that's the kind of
stuff you have to deal with when you're
working in these lower levels of
abstraction and that is it's a lot of
human labor to keep these kinds of
things going and so in order to focus
more on data I'll come back to this in a
bit but in order to focus more on actual
data and applications we have to kind of
move away from some of this complexity
and with the modern data stack this is
what we've seen right we've started to
hand off some of these details moving
from Hadoop to say a cloud distributed
data platform where someone else is
worrying about those things and I can
just worry about the queries and the
data maybe there are some low-level
things I have to do but I can start
handing off some of these lower levels
now the problem in real time is that we
haven't quite gotten there yet but
actually I'm going to argue that we're
pretty close and that the transformation
that needs to happen next is more of a
social and business transformation the
technology is kind of there waiting to
spread in our industry and I'm also
going to talk about how that transition
could go very wrong if we don't handle
it correctly
okay so I talked about the cost of
complexity
now I'm going to show you an even more
complex architecture and I'm going to
tell you how this is super complicated
but also better for people using the
system so notice now let me kind of
explain what's happening here it's a lot
of stuff going on here
um before I was feeding my system with
one application database and the data
went to two paths and so this is a One
path architecture and it also abstracts
away the complexities of querying two
systems so my application database you
have change data capture running change
data capture pulls the changes off that
database in other words as Rights happen
into that database they get detected and
passed into a queue and then those go
into an event buffer so the event buffer
collects these events and that's my
real-time part and then I have a
non-real-time part because the real-time
part has scalability limitations in
other words it might be running on Rams
so it's really fast or SSD but it will
run out of space eventually and so I
need to have another batch part which is
on the right that's the table commit
part so the table commit part is like a
conventional analytics database think
Hadoop or snowflake or bigquery it's
like handles large amounts of data and
can scan very efficiently and so the
idea is that over time I have an
automated system that rolls up events
out of the event buffer and then dumps
them into the batch part and takes care
of that detail for me
now of course this is complicated right
because I assume that I've got Engineers
running all of this stuff they have to
think about all these moving parts and
manage it but at least for the user
these details are taken care of okay now
what about the part where before I had
to query two separate systems
well now I'm going to have a quarry
orchestrator that takes care of that for
me so that
my data scientist or my analyst can just
type a query the query goes to the query
orchestrator the query orchestrator
decides this is the data that's in the
real-time part this other data is in the
bad part runs two queries combines the
results and returns them seamlessly and
so I just see output spit out for the
user it's fantastic for Ops it's a huge
pain Ops it's not going to be happy
about this because actually I have like
how many databases do I have running in
this architecture secretly I have like
four different database so remember I
said that to get around the cap there
and the trick is instead of having one
database you have multiple databases
that do different things and satisfy
different constraints so I have my
application database secretly I didn't
put this in the diagram but I have like
an event stream buffer something like
Kafka that's really another type of
database or data store I'm an event
buffer and I have this batch piece over
in the upper right hand corner so four
different databases a whole bunch of
things to maintain
okay
um does anyone know what this is
you've probably seen some cartoons like
this before what do we call these
it's a Rube Goldberg machine yeah so
this thing I built is awesome but it's
starting to look like a Rube Goldberg
machine it's super super complicated
except that if we think about it we've
got a lot of Ruby Goldberg machines
working behind the scenes that work
perfectly if we get an adequate level of
Automation and management in place so
for example the aircraft I flew I flew
back from Amsterdam to the United States
on a Boeing's Triple 7 aircraft
incredibly complicated machine two
engines all kinds of systems all kinds
of computer automation to make sure that
the aircraft flies correctly back in the
1960s they actually had to have three
people flying that aircraft they had an
engineer that would help manage the
systems and then two pilots and then in
the late 1960s they got rid of the
engineer and were able to automate
things enough plus train the pilots to
do more engineering so that you went
down to two pilots and in Tech we're
still kind of in that phase where we
need engineering but we're maybe doing
more engineering than we need to be
doing in a typical company and so by
hiding the abstractions the Rube
Goldberg machine we can have something
that behaves seamlessly for application
developers and analysts so they don't
have to think about a lot of these
details
okay so I'm going to come back to this
idea the super complicated thing here
when we think about the modern data
stack what is the modern data stack well
it's really the it's managed Services
it's taking all this complexity that we
used to have to manage ourselves in
Hadoop and managing it for us so we can
just think about our data
and now I'm going to tell you that this
is actually something where I could set
this up in an hour it turns out I'm not
I'm trying not to use the names of
vendors too much today because I want to
talk more about general terms and
general Trends and not about specific
vendors if you're curious I can tell you
more about where this comes from but
this is actually an architecture that a
vendor offers more or less off-the-shelf
fully managed there are a couple of
things that I would have to set up for
you to do a demo so I'd have to set up a
managed application database some kind
of SQL database like postgres I'd have
to set up a manage queue and then I'd be
able to set up this other piece that
would handle all the queries and the
real time and the batch part and the
roll up for me more or less
automatically and so
this is this is technology that's
available today but I think the cultural
shift that Embraces this version of real
time hasn't really happened yet and I I
compare it to what happened with the
modern data stack the modern data stack
actually didn't happen overnight I think
the kickoff for the modern data stack
was the release of Google bigquery back
in 2010. a long long time ago right that
was over a decade ago and it took a
while for people to notice that this
technology was available so until like
2016 or so Hadoop was all the rage like
setting up your own big cluster very
complicated to manage very complicated
to run that was what people were doing
and yet there was this other technology
that could man automate a lot of those
processes for you in terms of the social
part it took a while just to get that
message out there so specifically I
remember looking at bigquery in 2016 I
was like reading their documentation at
the time I was using an on-prem MPP data
system requiring large amounts of data
and I was also using Hadoop in parallel
and I looked at the documentation I
couldn't really understand what Bitcoin
was for like what what is this system
exactly and these tools that allow us to
combine batch from real time like this
are already out there but it's going to
take a while for that to get socialized
and for us to figure out data
applications built around these tools
um who has heard from a major there's a
major database vendor again I'm not
naming names too specifically the claims
that they will have a database in the
near future that does transactional and
analytics all in one okay you've
probably heard these claims
fundamentally what is that well I'm I'm
betting almost like 99 chance that it's
something like this architecture right
what they're doing behind the scenes is
running something like this for you
and then letting you just worry about
your data not having to worry about
those details anymore of managing all
these moving parts and components
okay so what does this let us do as
analytics Engineers data Engineers
application engineers
well we can start thinking of having
these moving parts inside of a box where
instead of having to manage all the
moving parts we can just connect to the
box and build our data application I
should be clear here there are
definitely companies that need to worry
about all this complexity right if I'm
operating at the scale of Google this is
what this is my business this is what I
do I sell cloud services so if I'm
operating at the scale of AWS this is
what I do this is what I offer to
customers
um but Google and Amazon have entire
teams Google has a huge team that works
on just Google Colossus which is just
their storage system The Backs a bunch
of other products and Amazon has a huge
team that works on Amazon S3 which flat
backs all kinds of other products and so
we're getting to the point where those
abstractions are handled by large tech
companies but small startups in
Enterprises are just going to see
something more like this
and so ultimately it becomes more of a
black box although we need to kind of
understand what's happening behind the
scenes to make sure that we use the tool
appropriately
eventually
I think we're at the cusp of a point
where we'll be able to think of this
type of tool as a database one database
with two interfaces and so what do I
mean by that well you still need you
need acid right for your applications
you have to maintain consistent State
you have to be able to handle thousands
of transactions per second you
simultaneously want to be able to run
analytics on that application and so
let's think about the possibilities with
this kind of architecture where you can
dispense with the complexity of managing
all these tools say I'm an airline and
right now I look at taking my baggage
management system and making it real
time as an incredibly complicated
proposition I have to set up CDC into a
target maybe a Kafka stream and from
there I need to add a stream processor
of some kind and each of these moving
parts has a lot of management involved
and I'm an airline I'm not a tech
company and so I have a really hard time
recruiting the talent that can do these
kinds of things I have a hard time
managing those teams I'm not going to be
able to continue with Google in these
kinds of operations but once we get to
the point where this becomes more of a
black box where I can deploy something
off the shelf with multiple interfaces
and so I can have on the one side in a
transactional interface that handles all
the updates to my state as new events
happen as I get information about where
bags are located and on the other side I
have an analytics interface where I can
run SQL queries or run streaming queries
and I can see what's going on with bags
at scale so I can run a query the
queries everything that's happening with
bags on that aircraft without
overwhelming my transactional system and
so now suddenly I have a data
application where I can provide a better
experience for customers and so
customers now will see more in real time
about what's happening with their bags
where if a flight takes off it triggers
an analytics job that says let's look at
the state of all these bags and let's
find out what's going on with them and
if there's a problem then I start
sending out alerts and other systems
um and I guess at some point here I'm
taking a fairly simple picture of this
it turns out that with real time you can
think either in terms of batch queries
or in terms of windowed queries which I
think are a more modern approach to the
problem so with batch queries I'm still
just running SQL I'm doing things like
querying all the data for the last six
weeks including the latest data that's
just coming in with windowed queries I
can do things like operational analytics
where I look at the last five minutes of
a stream and I collect statistics
consistently on the last five minutes of
a stream and wherever maybe I emit new
results every couple seconds and so with
these new abstractions my analytics
Engineers my data Engineers my machine
learning Engineers can just focus on
writing the jobs that do that stream
processing or batch processing on
real-time data without again worrying
about the underlying details of the
architecture
now what I'm going to say here is this
is not going to replace the modern data
stack from my perspective there are
still a lot of things that just need to
be batched and probably will be for the
foreseeable future and specifically what
I've seen as a consultant and just
working with various companies is that
companies that have tried to dump all
their data into real-time systems
generally don't succeed it's just it's
as they call it boiling the ocean right
it's way too complicated and it doesn't
have a specific goal in mind also many
data sources are not very suitable for
real-time analytics so think about for
example third-party data that comes in
and you're only allowed to access it in
a batch it's a very common scenario and
I actually think for privacy reasons
that's going to become more and more the
case we've seen this in ad Tech right ad
Tech a few years ago was much more real
time they're starting to cut back on
real time because Real Time with that
type of data can create very serious
privacy issues and as that becomes more
of a concern some data is just going to
arrive in batch
but internally within the companies that
you work for there are almost always
opportunities to deploy real time in a
way that will move the needle on the
business and so that comes back to for
example the airline example or another
example that I saw was a company that
couldn't keep track of their inventory
and so they would often sell things they
didn't have so that's a great
opportunity for real time to augment
that company's capabilities and better
serve their customers
but I guess the the summary here is that
instead of focusing on making everything
real time we should use the modern data
stack for what it's meant for so for
really good analytics and Reporting and
then identify opportunities to deploy
real-time Technologies as we identify
business possibilities
um this is a Joe Reese coinage actually
and it also appears in our book and it's
a notion called the live data stack and
the idea of the live data stack is that
I start thinking of my application so I
build some kind of app and I start
thinking of it as a unified layer all
the way from the application data to
analytics and there are quite a few
applications where this is interesting
right now we think of those as being
partitioned and separate but what if I
can think about them as being unified in
certain cases so one one case that was
interesting is we had a client that was
um handling a lot of resumes and so they
would do resume processing for large
Enterprises and so quite often the
companies buying the SAS service were
interested in getting immediate near
what I'll call near real-time analytics
on the resumes that were coming in and
so they might be interested in seeing
how many people have applied for this
job in the last hour for example and
they're really struggling to make this
work I think in the future with some
notion of a live data stack when you
build that application from the get-go
it'll build in some analytics
assumptions for real-time data that you
can query without causing the back-end
database to topple over
another really critical thing that we
need to talk about is accountability and
best practices
so it turns out that real-time data has
has kind of gotten a black eye if you
followed technology over the several
over the last several years because of
issues with privacy
anything that you can do that's bad with
data can be much worse if it's done in
real time which means that as we deploy
more real-time applications we have to
think very carefully about what we're
doing with data and how we're protecting
people's privacies and how data could be
misused to make sure that it's not
misused so for example I'm aware of a
company a few years back that was
um basically your phone
has what's called the it has a hardware
Network address something called a MAC
address and the macro address gets
broadcast out as it's communicating with
the cellular network
now if your phone has a unique Mac
address it's always the same what does
that allow if I can listen into that Mac
address what could I do with that data
I can track people right there was a
company I was aware of that was doing
exactly that they figured out okay I can
put listeners all over town I can pick
up on people's Mac addresses and then I
can track their location
um and this of course that has some very
frightening privacy implications so if
you can track people a good actor could
use it to track bags moving through an
airport a bad actor can use this to
stalk people basically so that becomes
kind of terrifying so what happened to
this company is Apple figured out and
other cell phone vendors that this was
going on and so they came up with the
process called Mac address churning
where your Mac address randomly changes
to make sure that people can't track you
over time so basically this company
essentially shut down overnight I mean
they kind of were a shell of what they
were doing before they reframed
themselves as a traffic Tracking Company
because they can track devices in the
short term but not in the long term but
basically their business shut down and
that's because they weren't thinking
about the Privacy implications of the
things they were doing and the
terrifying aspects of this real-time
technology g whatever you do with
real-time applications you always need
to think about data privacy even in
batch but now it becomes much much more
critical so going back to location
tracking
location tracking in batch is
frightening right if I can look at
someone's location history I can get an
idea of what their movement patterns are
daily habits that is dangerous data but
if I can do it in real time then I can
know their location at any time which
poses a threat to their physical safety
this is a critical responsibility for
anyone who works with data you're
dealing with something that's a very
powerful tool that can harm people and
so as you're working with this new
generation of real-time applications you
have to make sure that things you're
doing help your customers and don't
potentially harm them like tracking
their bags as they're in the airport
moving from plane to plane going through
connections can be very helpful to your
their two customers
tracking bags as they're going home can
pose a threat to their safety in
addition that that's a key piece of
accountability right always keep track
of what bad actions could happen as a
consequence of the data you're
collecting
in addition we have to think about best
practices for
Building Systems and for
controlling costs so over the last year
we've seen a lot of debate and a lot of
a lot of argument online over the modern
data stack is the modern data stack dead
does the modern data stack cost too much
and I would say that most of these
debates come down to the fact that
people are using a tool that they don't
fully understand so why are people's
Cloud bills exploding well in many cases
they just have no notion of cost control
and appropriately running jobs that
aren't extremely expensive
um
why are we having privacy issues with
data well in many cases these tools are
so easy to set up that people haven't
had any privacy training before they're
turned loose on a very powerful system
that can run massive queries over data
that might contain sensitive data as we
see deployment of more real-time
Technologies we need to start training
people before they're given access to
these tools that makes to make sure that
they understand the business
implications of the tools they're using
and once again the Privacy implications
that I was talking about before
and I'll stop there it was a pleasure to
talk to you today this is my email
address my LinkedIn and I also have a
Twitter at Dr Housley which is super
pretentious I'm trying to get into
tweeting more and uh I'm I'm excited to
talk to you guys after the talk about
this discussion
thank you